Bike Night brings together art music and
motorcycles it happens the third Friday
of every month and this Friday there is
a National Lampoon's holiday twist so
joining us now is Tara and Santa Steve
with Main Street Mota welcome you guys
all right thank you thanks for being
here so what is vintage bike nights what
what happens down there on that third
Friday
so what we've been doing vintage by
ignite every month for 12 years now in
the arts district and originally there
wasn't back in you know 12 years ago
there wasn't much happening in the arts
district you know especially motorcycle
related so
um we do it every month it is just a fun
casual fun event where we get all sorts
of bikes but we like to highlight the
Vintage bikes and for this month we have
a special holiday feature
um based on the National Lampoon's uh
movie and and theme right everybody's
favorite yeah holidays exactly and we
also have a family truckster sidecar
bike that we built that this kind of
event is featured around I always see it
here now we say is this Santa Steve said
to Steve on this bike cruising around
it's right out of National Lampoon's
Vacation right there cruising around Las
Vegas now got Clark Griswold on the back
there oh my gosh cool so so with this
Friday night uh there's there's
obviously the holiday themes we're just
talking about are there any contests
ugly sweaters what's happening now yeah
yeah so we wanted to increase absolutely
go ahead all right this looks so natural
if you can get it started you can write
it off
so we have a costume like a sweater yeah
yeah so we want we encourage everyone to
come you know dressed in festive gear
particularly your favorite National
Lampoon's character or ugly sweater any
Christmas character just to to have fun
with it we will be having contests and
giving away prizes we have VIP tickets
available for this particular event it's
free to attend but if you want to get a
good deal on getting a meal and drinks
and dessert and a special little gift
bag that we have put together you can
get those tickets
um there's a link off of our website get
on our website yeah now I'm Santa Steve
I don't own a bike but I do I do love
the bike culture you know is that open
to everyone now did you have a bike to
come down or it's open to everyone it's
open to everybody what's up everybody
it's just a gathering for for
like-minded folks that love motorcycle
Cycles hot rod cars I mean we see all
kinds of stuff down there sometimes and
there's music entertainment Friday yes
yes we've always got live music
um and there's food drink and good times
and cool bikes and really cool bikes
thank you so much for joining us Merry
Christmas YouTube can I ride this one
out I need the key I need the key to get
started all right uh yeah yeah check out
the Vintage bike nights it's National
Lampoon's holiday party it's happening
Friday downtown at 18 bin for more
information go to mainstreetmoto.com Las
Vegas